this was pretty much the last episode
for the time being at least there I got
into the details of areas as you could
see at the moment just trying to get
some more stuff onto these facades might
want to explain that for a tiny bit
since realistically I would have to have
just completely flat facades no
differences between the buildings how
much they stick out whatsoever since
that's just not what Dutch buildings do
at least not in a cityscape sort of way
and they certainly don't do around the
canals of Amsterdam for example but I
wanted to get some sort of depth in
there because otherwise it was just way
too well bland and boring really so
that's why these hanging baskets as
always I know I am very much addicted to
these hanging baskets I can never just
not place them but that's one thing and
just trying to get some nice cornices in
there pillars
arches whatever I could really do to
just get a tiny bit of depth out there
without having to change the facade or
move the building as a whole so that's
kind of these small details that I did
over there but this is actually the last
episode for the time being like I said
in which I want to do those smaller
details since in the later half of this
episode I'm actually gonna go into the
the more rural sort of area of the touch
part of the park
which is going to be on that little
island I want to have some typical
wooden buildings over there if you don't
know about this there are basically two
sort of styles that I wanted to get in
here since there is the very famous sort
of Amsterdam look the real city look
which also packs a lot from other
European cultures in a way as well
definitely wanted to get that City canal
in there as well but I also wanted to
sort of get a tiny bit of the rural
Dutch look in there too which is usually
they would have very simple little
houses or the same sort of tiled roofs
that we kind of have over here and same
Gables really same sort of shapes with
the stepped gables and the clock cables
and all that good stuff but with wooden
walls which are usually painted green or
blue which is not that common of a site
I think it's it it's like mostly in
North Holland but it's definitely
something that I want to get in there
especially if I wanted to get that
typical Dutch windmill I can't I I
cannot not put that Dutch windmill on
there that would
be the thing you can't do is it's a
[ __ ] touch area I need to get that in
there but I was worried about the fact
that you know if I put that in there and
really wanted to get a tiny bit of that
more rural sort of feel to it I didn't
want to have that windmill in the middle
of a city area it wouldn't only be
dwarfed by the buildings around it but I
would feel like it just fits more in a
bit of a farm ish area so that's also
why I wanted to get that in so that's
gonna be the second part of this video
by the way I I'm still not sure like
about these bricks of the corner
building I mean those bricks are from
CTR sins I think it's called the Dutch
colonial set though to touch sets I
think this is from the colonial one
which I have actually been [ __ ] on
quite a bit and always saying that it
doesn't really fit too much for Dutch
parks which it does have really good
windows in there but the textures in a
way aren't really too good but over here
I think it does sort of fits it is a bit
too light really for a Dutch sort of
building but then again it's a theme
park it can be a tiny bit lighter that
is something that you'll often find
actually that's recreations of whatever
sort of thing in real life and theme
parks are just a tiny bit more bright
tiny bit more appealing in that way to
the eye but yeah that's why I figured
that would be good because basically I
tried to make a gable that sort of
stepped gable for a brick texture that I
already had and I just made it in a
completely [ __ ] up way it was supposed
to be like a one tile gable but I
extensively just ended up making it to
tile white cable that sounds like the
weirdest thing ever that sounds like
accidentally building a shelf but yeah
it actually happened and that it was
like oh [ __ ] all this I'm not gonna
really important that thing make it
smaller so actually figure that that CT
or since wall could work gave it a bit
of a chance there and it actually works
what do you know so that was actually
pretty good and the only other thing
that I wanted to get in here it's hide a
bit more and if all that's done then I
would call this Dutch facade over here
pretty much done it's just some simple
foliage around its foliage is too
important I can never stress that enough
and not just that it's always it's
always fun to place flowers but you know
that I'm the flower fetishes there's it
doesn't really matter anyway I just
wanted to get that in
this was a bit of an off topic thing I
think this was actually the end of the
particular stream that I felt like okay
I want to get the trolley in I'm not
gonna have the track yet but I just want
to make sure that I get that sort of
layouts done actually made a
surprisingly large impact on how this
entire area looks as a whole the only
thing that's sort of wrong with it is
it's not completely symmetrical
I made of course the asymmetrical little
square over here in the middle of the
park but yeah than it turned out that I
couldn't get the trolley in in a
symmetrical way I do so there's like
tiny bits wrong with the curves
technically now I don't have OCD so I'm
not too worried about that at the moment
but I might still change that at some
later stage in any case this is the tiny
bit of the touch areas that's gonna
happen in a tiny bit here some people
actually many people I think were a tiny
bit worried I'm gonna stop saying that
next next drinking game is gonna be
everything every every time silver rat
says tinier bits you have to take a shot
[ __ ] people are hammered at this
point but yeah so many people were
asking if I was ever going to get any
sort of ride or anything else in the
Dutch area it's not going to be
completely empty don't worry it's not
gonna be just buildings over here I
would get a restaurant in in these
buildings as somehow it's got to be that
little chair swing which I ripped from
the efteling things and actually fits
really well it's almost a tiny bit of a
focus it's always it's a tiny bit very
Dutch looking chair swing if there's
ever such a thing it's just it's the
efteling and it looks exactly like the
one in the earthling so that's why I
figured it would like enough of a Dutch
look to sort of fit in here and the main
sort of challenge that I had when I was
doing this restaurant is obviously you
can see me getting those 1h while those
one tile steps cables in and all that
stuff
I wanted to get those cables in it it's
not as basically Dutch architecture in a
nutshell that's what it's known for
having those very small houses or very
narrow houses in the case of Amsterdam
with those fancy cables on top of it and
the rest of the building is usually just
simple so I wanted to really
I wanted to really focus on those cables
as well for this building but yeah it's
really hard to actually make a one
building that doesn't consist out of
multiple different parts but rather is
just one big square or whatever have
different Gables without making it look
a tiny bit weird it's by the way there
is a bit of a thunderstorm going on
outside I hope you don't notice that too
much yeah [ __ ] I shouldn't be
recording this with a blue Yeti probably
the better gate I don't really care too
much well yeah that was the main sort of
challenge but I wanted to go for was a
tiny bit vague I don't know what it is
I'm just gonna forget about that what I
wanted to get over here was a building
that was just square kind of square but
not entirely of course I did want to get
some corners in there but the basic
premise was just a building with many
different facades like this and then
build around that to make it look like a
restaurant and that was absolutely the
most horrible idea to start off with I
had no other idea like usually when I
start off with a building and this is
what I would usually recommend if you
will decide to build a building of any
sorts is that you have some kind of plan
you don't really have to sketch it out
on paper like some people do but just at
least it isn't much just have build an
idea in your head of what you want to do
with it and you may be able to see that
at the time that I was building this I
had no idea whatsoever what it was gonna
turn into so it was basically crossing
my fingers and doing whatever I came up
with and hoping that it would look good
at some point I felt like I don't think
I can come up with anything for that
restaurant decided to build those couple
of walls for a second but that didn't
really work out either so just decided
okay I want to get some sort of
overlapping little roof that's gonna
almost connect to that little flying
thing little chair swing and then I
would want to have the tables and chairs
underneath that because it's Holland it
always rains over here it's bad weather
it floats everywhere you know you want
to have some sort of coverage so your
fries don't get [ __ ] wet so that's
why I wanted to have that and just
decide okay [ __ ] it I'm just gonna try
and build that first get that in there
and then see if that's
any sort of thing to work around and
after I got this thing in wanted to get
a tiny bit of detail on it that's what I
got this thing in I actually had some
ideas of how I wanted to do this and how
this was going to look in a way that I
really won in it too so that actually
really helped and this is the sort of
idea that I had just have that bit of an
overlapping roof on top of the whatever
part of the restaurant that has going to
be and behind that to have the main part
of the building in a way kind of like
you would have uncommon gone and I think
we also just kind of have that
overlapping little thing where you have
restaurants on top of it and after that
you have the facades of the roof and
that's basically how this is going to
work as well and yeah this is
practically the only real way how I
could achieve two things that I really
wanted to get I really wanted to get
those different Gables in there those
the looks like these are really tiny
houses while at the same time creating a
large building and that's also what I
wanted to have like I wanted to make a
large restaurant over here at least
large enough to cater to everyone who
wanted to sit down and eat in the Dutch
area but I did want to keep that a very
small rural charm to it like it's a
country house I've listened how okay
never mind
um so yeah that's how I sort of wanted
to do that and at that point I think
this is basically how it's gonna be just
need to still add details to it of
course but this is going to be the basic
sort of shape of the building and how I
really want to do it so eventually it
did end up working I was a very happy
person at that point because I was
really really afraid that this was going
to turn into nothing basically and this
building was quite important for me
since it had to sort of form the
connection between the Italian / Spanish
Mediterranean area and these Dutch
facades that I already had over here I
was quite happy with both but there was
nothing in between them just empty ugly
grassland and what does get rid of that
and get some sort of nice building in
there and this is really going to help
in the end I do still have that tiny bit
of concrete on the other side of the
flying chairs wing that is also going to
hopefully have some buildings on it
the other side of the path so just
completely on the other side of this
little island I'm once you have the
windmill and the idea is to maybe place
a little like a little playground on it
since there is a playground set from
Pat's with also to touch playground
things and I would be pretty good but
that's something for later time and I
definitely have to explain this for a
tiny bit though I will probably make a
special video about there's no [ __ ]
anyway now I'm gonna make a special
video about this since it's like the end
of this video and this is gonna not be
relevant anymore after today or tomorrow
but it doesn't really matter tomorrow I
would like to stream on YouTube and do a
pisode 100 live I want to do something
special for episode 100 and I feel like
a live stream on YouTube if YouTube this
is actually work because we all know how
shitty YouTube livestream services that
would be really amazing when we stuck
with like non copyright music or
something but anyway it's gonna be
really awesome hopefully and I'll
release a tiny bit of a more explanatory
video later on today I think or tomorrow
morning something like that in any case
thank you guys for watching and usual
thing I'll see you guys later